>> SALLY: Weiß Murat Bescheid, dass wir anfangen?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht. Wo ist der gerade?
[Toilettenspülung]
>> SALLY: Murat?
Warst du jetzt ernsthaft noch auf dem Klo?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Ich muss. Tut mir leid.
>> SALLY: Was machst du?
>> MURAT: Mir ist kalt.
>> SALLY: Was?!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich habe die Heizung runtergedreht ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Du Schwabe.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Musste sein.
Oh!
So.
>> SALLY: Können wir starten?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Gutes neues Jahr. Frohes neues Jahr.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt mit Murat!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Wir haben uns gedacht, das letzte Video
aus dem Jahr 2020 soll ein Frage-Antwort-Video sein,
also ein Q&A.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich dachte mir,
ich muss Frage-Antwort ausformulieren.
>> MURAT: Das heißt Question and Answer auf Englisch
für die, wo keinen Leistungskurs in Englisch hatten.
>> SALLY: Oder ein S&C, soru ve cevap.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: Türkisch.
Ja.
Und da haben wir jetzt ganz viele Fragen gesammelt von euch.
Die werden wir beantworten.
Dann werden wir ein bisschen aufs Jahr zurückschauen.
Und dann machen wir ein "Wer würde eher ...?"
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Da bin ich schon sehr gespannt drauf.
>> MURAT: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Also ich habe mir jetzt mal hier
ein paar Screenshots von euren Fragen gemacht.
Ich würde sagen, wir starten direkt.
Und zwar fragt die Melek:
"Welches Gericht könntest du jeden Tag essen?"
>> MURAT: Welches Gericht könnte ich jeden Tag essen?
>> SALLY: Bei mir ist es Ofengemüse.
>> MURAT: Oh, ich mag gern
Spaghetti Bolognese. Ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Das könntest du auch jeden Tag essen?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich bin gerade da voll Fall davon.
>> SALLY: "Wie habt ihr euch
die Namen der Kinder ausgesucht?"
>> MURAT: Wir haben gewürfelt.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss sagen,
bei Samira wollte ich zuallererst
Nisa haben oder Anisa,
aber wir haben ja schon eine Nisa in der Familie,
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: deine Nichte.
Und deswegen war dann so
– ja, ich habe halt durch so Kinderbüchernamen geblättert.
Und das haben wir so ausgesucht.
Und die Ela hat die Samira ausgesucht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Zuerst wollte sie
– die hat nämlich damals so eine türkische Serie geguckt.
Da wollte sie, dass die Ela Hayri heißt.
Aber Hayri ist ein Männername.
Und dann haben wir ihr das gesagt,
dass Ela ein Mädchen wird.
Und dann hat sie irgendwo Ela aufgeschnappt
und hat gesagt: "Das wird jetzt eine kleine Ela."
"Was habt ihr gedacht,
als ihr euch das erste Mal gesehen habt?"
>> MURAT: Mh.
>> SALLY: Ich gedacht: "Hübsch, aber klein."
>> MURAT: Ehrlich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das ist nicht lustig.
>> SALLY: Aber das habe ich gedacht.
Ich war doch nur ehrlich.
Ich habe mir gedacht:
"Ein hübscher Mann, aber zu klein für mich."
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich hatte sieben erfolgreiche Jahre vor dir.
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Jetzt kommt die lange Dürre."
Ja, war supercool.
Ja.
Sorry, aber das ist einfach jetzt mal zurückgehauen.
So. Das war es halt. So.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Kommen wir gleich zur nächsten Frage:
"Streitet ihr oder ist alles harmonisch und perfekt?"
>> MURAT: Nee, wir streiten oft.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte gerade so
>> MURAT: Nee, kann man doch sagen.
>> SALLY: wie bei Rosamunde Pilcher...
>> MURAT: Halt! Stopp! Jetzt rede ich!
>> SALLY: Pst!
>> MURAT: Hochnäsige Zicke.
Auf jeden Fall, wir streiten oft.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir streiten echt oft.
>> MURAT: Muss man ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Aber warum streiten wir?
>> MURAT: Wegen dir.
>> SALLY: Josh?
Okay, du musst nichts dazu sagen.
Max, Vivi, ihr müsst auch nichts dazu sagen.
Ich würde mal vielleicht sagen,
dass ich der harmonischere Part von uns bin
und eher der geduldige, der über alles spricht,
und Murat eher der emotionale Part ist,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: aus dem auch gern mal
die Emotion heraussprudelt.
>> MURAT: Ja, so ist es. Ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Aber du meinst es ja nie böse.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Er schlägt mich manchmal,
aber er meint es nie böse.
Nein, Spaß.
>> MURAT: Genau. Einfach so, dass man es nicht sieht.
Nee.
Es ist...
Es ist einfach so. Man streitet oft.
Also wir streiten oft, weil wir auch...
>> SALLY: Ja. Mein Gott!
Aber dann versöhnt man sich halt wieder.
>> MURAT: Ja. Das Problem ist halt, dass wir zusammen
>> SALLY: arbeiten.
>> MURAT: leben und arbeiten.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Er geht mir halt manchmal auf die Nerven.
Aber das ist okay.
Und ich finde dafür, dass wir 24 Stunden zusammen sind,
also arbeiten und zusammen leben und hier wohnen,
finde ich, ist unsere Beziehung echt gut.
>> MURAT: Scheidung ist zu teuer.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss schon sagen:
Also, wenn wir dann mal alleine sind,
was wir selten sind, weil wir echt
– mit Kindern und allem ist man halt nicht mehr so oft allein.
Aber dann sind wir schon ein süßes Ehepaar.
>> MURAT: Ja, dann streiten wir auch nicht,
weil wir Fernsehen schauen.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach!
Er macht jede Romantik wieder kaputt.
Aber ich muss sagen, er ist sehr lustig.
Also das schon.
"Warum schließt ihr den Laden?"
Ja, das machen wir nicht aus Lust und Laune.
>> MURAT: Oder weil es draußen regnet.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir mussten halt zumachen.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir mussten den Laden...
>> SALLY: Wegen dem Lockdown.
>> MURAT: Genau. Wir mussten den Laden leider schließen.
Dagegen kannst du nichts machen.
Aber...
Wie soll ich es sagen?
>> SALLY: Ich meine, wir haben den Laden,
unseren Laden in Mannheim eröffnet zu Corona-Zeiten.
Also unsere Eröffnung war ja eigentlich im April,
am 4.4. geplant.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und als wir die Eröffnung geplant haben,
gab es noch kein Corona.
Und dann kam eben Corona
und der Lockdown, der erste.
Und wir haben den Laden trotzdem im Mai eröffnet.
Und es war echt eine schwierige Zeit.
Aber ich muss sagen, so den Sommer über
und den Herbst über war es dann echt schön.
Wir hatten viele Besucher,
haben auch die ganzen Hygienekonzepte
und Regeln beachtet.
Dass jetzt halt noch mal ein Lockdown kommt,
ich glaube, damit hat doch keiner gerechnet.
Aber ich meine, man muss halt das Beste daraus machen.
>> MURAT: Doch, der Dorsten hat das schon vorhergesagt.
>> SALLY: Ja, stimmt. Stimmt. Er wusste es.
>> MURAT: Der wusste das im März schon.
>> SALLY: Wir hätten auf ihn hören sollen.
Ja, mein Gott. Wir...
>> MURAT: Das hätte auch nichts geändert, aber...
>> SALLY: Ich muss sagen, wir
können uns echt nicht beschweren.
Wir haben unseren Onlineshop.
Und ich glaube, da gibt es Unternehmen,
denen geht es echt ganz, ganz schlecht damit,
weil sie eben online nicht so fit sind wie wir.
Und deswegen muss ich schon sagen:
Es ist schade und macht uns auch sehr traurig,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: vor allem, weil wir gerade
weihnachtlich dekoriert haben
und jetzt irgendwie nur drei Wochen was davon hatten.
Aber es ist halt so. Wir machen das Beste daraus.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Dafür machen wir jetzt Inventur, räumen auf.
>> MURAT: Das hat alles seine Richtigkeit.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und ja...
>> SALLY: So ist es.
"Wer ist anstrengender,
Murat oder Ela?"
Die Frage ist wohl an mich gerichtet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> MURAT: Also die Ela ärgert mich.
>> SALLY: Ich wir dir nicht zu nahe treten,
aber ich finde, Murat ist anstrengender.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Denn Ela ist ein Kind
und sie hört dann auch irgendwann auf mich.
Vielleicht nicht beim ersten Mal,
aber es ist schon so, wenn ich sage:
"Ela, jetzt ist aber echt genug,
jetzt wirklich, jetzt ist Feierabend",
dann hört sie auf.
Der Murat macht weiter.
Er macht es dann nur so weiter
– der Josh lacht schon hinter der Kamera.
Der macht dann so weiter,
dass ich irgendwann nicht mehr ernst bleiben kann
und wirklich darüber lachen muss.
Aber eigentlich bin ich stinkestinkesauer
und will einfach
und sage immer: "Murat, jetzt hör endlich auf!"
Aber, weil ich den Lachflash des Todes habe...
>> MURAT: Ich kann dann
– ich fühle mich dann irgendwie...
Wenn mir jemand sagt:
[Hundeknurren]
"Hör auf" oder so,
dann kann ich einfach nicht anders.
Das ist dann in mir drin.
Dann eskaliert das halt.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Deine Mutter hat das erzählt,
dass das dein Papa auch immer gemacht hat.
Die hat immer gesagt: "Der hat mich so geärgert!
Der hat mich so geärgert!"
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber...
>> SALLY: Und dann hat sie immer gesagt:
>> MURAT: Ich weiß nicht.
>> SALLY: "Aber der hat mich bestimmt geliebt,
weil er mich so geärgert hat."
>> MURAT: Ja.
So. Was sich neckt, das liebt sich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und ich liebe dich wahnsinnig.
Deswegen ärgere ich dich auch wahnsinnig.
>> SALLY: Hör trotzdem auf damit!
[Hundeknurren]
>> MURAT: Ja. Ja, so ist es.
[Hundejaulen]
>> SALLY: "Wünscht ihr euch für eure Kinder
einen 'normalen' Job oder geht auch YouTube?"
Einen normalen Job.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Muss ich echt sagen.
>> MURAT: Also mir wäre es eigentlich egal.
>> SALLY: Ich...
>> MURAT: Hauptsache, sie sollen keine Kunst
und keine Germanistik studieren.
Ansonsten habe ich...
>> SALLY: Bei dir wäre ein Germanistik-Studium
echt gut gewesen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn die Ela und die Samira,
wenn die Schreiner werden möchten,
dann sollen sie Schreiner werden.
Wenn sie Floristen werden möchten,
Friseur werden möchten...
>> SALLY: Egal was.
>> MURAT: Egal was.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, Hauptsache, sie lernen was.
Und der Beruf als YouTuber ist halt so,
den kann man nicht lernen.
Deswegen, finde ich, hat man da keine Grundlage.
Und vor allem, wenn man das Ganze als Job sieht
und jobmäßig damit anfängt, glaube ich
– ich will jetzt keinem zu nahe treten,
aber ich finde, das ist die falsche Motivation.
Wir haben ja auch damit angefangen,
weil es uns Spaß macht,
beziehungsweise ich.
Und dann wurde es irgendwann zum Job.
>> MURAT: So ist es.
>> SALLY: Aber ich habe ja nicht damit angefangen als Beruf.
>> MURAT: Die meisten Leute, wenn man mal fragt,
was sie heute machen,
machen sie eigentlich alle was anderes,
als sie eigentlich als Ausbildungsberuf gemacht haben.
Das kommt mit der Zeit.
Bei meinen Eltern war es so: Meinen Eltern war es egal.
Die haben gesagt: "Hauptsache, nicht kriminell.
Egal, was er macht, das ist in Ordnung."
Ich hätte alles werden können, Hauptsache, nicht kriminell.
Das war das Wichtige.
Und...
>> SALLY: Echt so.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und deswegen sagen sie immer, erfolgreich.
>> MURAT & SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und die Samira, die ist gerade momentan
auf einem Arzttrip.
Also die sagt immer: "Ich möchte Ärztin werden",
weil sie jetzt den Ali, den Dr. Ali kennengelernt hat,
und hat sich sogar so eine
– jetzt hat sie so eine Puppe mit Organen drin
und schreibt seit Tagen irgendwie
>> MURAT: Das nennt sich
>> SALLY: Heilkräuter...
>> MURAT: Tresor.
>> SALLY: Anatomie-Dingsda.
>> MURAT: Nee, Trosor.
Nee.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ding heißt.
>> JOSH: Torso meinst du.
>> MURAT: Ah, Torso, genau.
>> SALLY: Ah, danke, Josh!
>> MURAT: Torso. Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: Und ja, die ist so auf einem Ärztetrip
und schreibt jetzt immer so Heilkräuter raus
und deren Wirkung.
Und die Ela, die möchte
Tierärztin werden und Zahnfee.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sie hat gesagt, nachts ist sie dann die Zahnfee
und tagsüber die Tierärztin.
>> MURAT: Also ich würde immer gucken
– also unsere Kinder sowieso.
Vielleicht machen sie mal einen YouTube-Kanal
und nennen sich dann Sallys Töchter.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber
ich will, dass sie in die Schule gehen,
einen Ausbildungsberuf machen
– das ist mir ganz, ganz wichtig –
oder ein Studium oder irgendwas.
Und wenn sie das gemacht haben
und dann sie noch
>> SALLY: was anderes Kreatives machen
>> MURAT: was machen möchten, dann sollen sie machen.
>> SALLY: Aber unter ihrem eigenen Namen.
>> MURAT: Ansonsten sollen sie einfach richtig heiraten.
Das wäre auch wichtig.
Also das kann man auch machen.
>> SALLY: So wie du?
>> MURAT: Ja, zum Beispiel ich, wie der Papa.
Ja.
>> SALLY: "Ihr habt sehr früh geheiratet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Fluch oder Segen?"
Also ich muss sagen, bei uns war es eher Segen.
Also bei uns war es wirklich eine gute Entscheidung.
Jetzt ganz objektiv von außen betrachtet, finde ich,
muss eine Frau nicht unbedingt mit 19 heiraten.
Was hat mich damals geritten?
>> MURAT: Ich sage ja:
>> SALLY: Sag es nicht.
>> MURAT: Frauen heiraten, solange sie noch naiv sind.
Ja, aber das kann man nicht pauschalisieren.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Also es gibt echt Leute heutzutage...
Also vor 20, 30 Jahren haben 19-, 20-Jährige geheiratet,
ein Haus gebaut
und heute kriegen sie mit 25
noch nicht mal einen Handyvertrag. Also
>> SALLY: Ja, es ist echt so.
>> MURAT: es hat sich wirklich einiges
– aber da muss man auch sagen:
Leute, die damals mit 19, 20 geheiratet haben,
waren auch mit 23 geschieden.
Das kann auch vorkommen.
Also da kann man nichts pauschalisieren.
>> SALLY: Man kann es nicht auf das Alter beziehen.
Ich glaube, heiraten ist eine Einstellungssache.
Und da hat das Alter wenig damit zu tun.
Da hat eher so die Reife im Kopf damit zu tun.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und ja, man kann mit 40 heiraten
und es kann schiefgehen
oder man kann mit 20 heiraten und es kann gutgehen.
Von daher: Hört auf euer Bauchgefühl.
>> MURAT: Und ich denke halt,
weil wir halt zusammen immer so viel mitgemacht haben,
das heißt von den ganzen Anfängen,
Heiraten, Studium, Ausbildung,
>> SALLY: Ja. Und wir haben alles zusammen gemacht.
>> MURAT: und es uns dann aufgebaut haben,
erste Wohnung, erste Wohnung einrichten,
die Kinder sind gekommen
– ich weiß nicht woher –
und dann mit allem Drum und Dran.
Und wir haben alles zusammen erlebt
und das schweißt halt einen richtig zusammen.
>> SALLY: Ja, finde ich auch.
"Wie schafft ihr es, mit euren Mitarbeitern
Freunde und gleichzeitig die 'Chefs' zu sein?"
>> MURAT: Das ist nicht einfach,
muss man ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, es ist nicht einfach.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Es ist auch, das zu trennen nachher.
Aber ich finde...
>> SALLY: Ich erinnere mich nur an eine Situation gestern.
>> MURAT: Was?
>> SALLY: Da warst du mit dem Bahti im Termin
und ich habe draußen mit Josh und Sarah gewartet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir saßen in so einem Foyer
auf so Sesseln und haben da so
wie so
– ich glaube, von außen sah es aus
wie so drei Studenten, die nicht abgeholt wurden.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann sagt der Josh so:
"Ja, irgendwie voll witzig, weißt,
mit dir hier jetzt so abzuhängen und so",
weil ich gesagt habe:
"Hey, wir sehen aus wie so Studenten,
die nicht abgeholt wurden."
Und dann wusste ich genau, was er sagen will,
und er hat es nicht gesagt.
Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Ja, ich hänge mit euch hier ab,
aber ich überweise euch den Lohn am Ende des Monats."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich glaube, genau das ist es.
Also wir versuchen echt, mit jedem auf Augenhöhe zu sein.
Und ich mache jeden Spaß mit.
Also ich bin, glaube ich
– ich mache mich auch gern mal zum Affen hier für alle.
Mache ich wirklich, aber es ist natürlich auch schwer...
>> MURAT: Aber es hat alles seine Vor- und seine Nachteile.
Also...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ding, ich meine...
>> SALLY: Du musst halt auch die Leute dafür haben.
Also die Leute müssen halt trotzdem wissen so:
"Okay, ich kann mit ihr jeden Scheiß machen,
aber irgendwo..."
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es beschreiben soll.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht in jedem Unternehmen,
>> MURAT: Nee, das geht nicht in jedem.
>> SALLY: um es so zu sagen.
Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich glaube, wir haben das hier
ganz gut in der Waage.
>> MURAT: Denke ich auch.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> MURAT: Hm. Außer Güni, aber...
>> SALLY: Ja, gut, das ist ja ein
besonderer Fall.
>> MURAT: Es ist auch cool, wenn man jeden Morgen
reinkommt und einer erst mal einen
– jemand einen beleidigt aufs Übelste.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei euch auch normal ist,
dass ihr zu eurem Chef Sachen sagt,
wo ihr zu keinem sagen würdet.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, du hast auch genug
gegen ihn in der Hand.
Deswegen gründet er nie diesen Betriebsrat,
den er dir immer...
>> MURAT: Doch, den hat er schon gegründet.
>> SALLY: Ja, hat er schon?
>> MURAT: Ja, der hat alle angefuchst und
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: der will mich niedermachen.
Er hat gesagt, er gibt erst auf,
wenn er mich niedergemacht hat,
wenn er mich rausgejagt hat und dann alles Günis Welt ist.
>> SALLY: Okay.
"Schlaft ihr überhaupt noch
oder seid ihr nur Ideen am
– oder seid ihr nur am Ideenkreieren und -umsetzen?"
Also ich muss sagen, ich träume tatsächlich sehr oft
Dinge, die ich am nächsten Tag dann machen werde.
Also ich mache entweder oft Rezepte im Kopf fertig
oder Videos.
Es ist schon so, dass momentan
– vor allem jetzt zum Jahresende, muss ich echt sagen,
bin ich froh, dass jetzt Jahresende ist,
dass mal zwei Wochen das Büro zu ist.
Ich liebe mein Team über alles, aber ich bin auch froh,
wenn ich mal zwei Wochen zu Hause für mich habe,
einfach in Jogginghose rumlaufen kann
und mal nichts machen muss.
Nichts machen heißt einfach
nicht nichts machen, sondern
einfach mal sich nur um sich selber,
die Kinder und den Haushalt kümmern.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber, dass wir
– aber die Ideen, da ist es wirklich so:
Da braucht man ein cooles Team dahinter.
Und dann brauchst du echt die coolen Leute.
Ich sage es immer wieder, ich bin wie so ein Karnickel.
Wie
– ach!
Wie ein Hase.
Mein Gott! Dass man Karnickel
immer mit so einem negativen Ding reinbringt.
Ich bin wie so ein Hase,
der irgendwelche Löcher aufbuddelt.
Und dann brauche ich aber Leute, die das wieder zuschütten.
Das heißt, wenn wir eine Idee haben,
dann rede ich mit dem Dennis und sage:
"Dennis, guck mal. Wie denkst du darüber nach?
Und was könnten wir da machen?"
Dann denkt das der Dennis zu Ende
und macht das dann auch zu Ende.
Oder der Volkan oder der Bahti
oder der Josh oder die Sarah
und Aylin und wer auch immer.
Dass wir einfach Ideen bringen
und dass wir die Leute um uns haben,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: die das dann zu Ende denken
und zu Ende machen,
das ist das Coole.
Also immer so kleine Pieks,
so Initiativen geben
und dann wird es gemacht.
Und das ist cool.
Also ansonsten wirklich, wir denken
– ich denke von morgens bis abends.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich auch.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir haben jetzt zwei Wochen zu.
Kommt ihr trotzdem über die Feiertage mal?
>> MURAT: Nein, darfst du nicht.
>> SALLY: O Mann!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Wow! Das wird echt heftig.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Wer bestimmt abends das Fernsehprogramm?"
>> MURAT: Ich nicht.
Das kann ich ganz klar sagen.
>> SALLY: Also wir haben eine...
>> MURAT: Ich hasse das voll.
Ich würde einfach mal gern...
Ich will einfach eine
– können wir was Neues für das neue Jahr machen?
Darf ich einfach um 15 vor 8 die Tagesschau anschauen?
>> SALLY: Also wir machen es ja schon immer so,
dass ich die Kinder ins Bett bringe.
In der Zeit darf er seine Nachrichten gucken.
Denn ich hasse Nachrichten. Ich gucke so was nicht.
Ich kriege da schlechte Laune.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Allein schon die Nachrichtensprecher
– jetzt nichts gegen euch Nachrichtensprecher.
Ganz ehrlich. Ich mag ja auch viel von euch.
>> MURAT: Ich mag Nachrichten.
>> SALLY: Ich hasse diese Nachrichtensprecherstimmen.
Immer dieses...
>> MURAT: Ich finde es cool.
>> SALLY: Dieses Strenge, Unemotionale.
Ich weiß, ihr müsst das so machen.
Aber ich hasse Nachrichten.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich finde es cool.
>> SALLY: Also guck du ruhig um acht deine Nachrichten.
>> MURAT: Und das Schlimme ist dann,
dass die Filme, die mir gefallen,
ihr nicht gefallen.
Also ich liebe Dokumentationen, ich liebe...
>> SALLY: Historisches.
>> MURAT: Historische Filme liebe ich über alles.
>> SALLY: Nope.
>> MURAT: Und sie mag halt einfach so
>> SALLY: Also entweder muss jemand sterben...
>> MURAT: Frauenfilme.
Ganz
– ich weiß nicht. Darf ich das sagen?
Heutzutage, ich glaube,
darf man das gar nicht mehr sagen, gell?
>> SALLY: Also
>> MURAT: So Frauenfilme.
>> SALLY: meine Filmauswahl
oder Serienauswahl ist echt so.
Entweder ist es ein Frauenfilm
oder es muss jemand dabei sterben.
Ich glaube, das mag ich einfach, so Thriller und Krimi.
Aber zu psycho darf es auch nicht sein,
also so, dass ich dann Angst bekomme.
Aber so zwei, drei Morde sind schon gut.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja. Und ich liebe wirklich nur
so historische Filme,
>> SALLY: Auf wahrer Begebenheit.
>> MURAT: auf wahrer Begebenheit,
Dokumentationen.
Wirklich auch Filme, die mich persönlich weiterbringen
und wo ich was lernen kann.
Genau.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber gerade so Sachen
auf wahrer Begebenheit, muss ich sagen
– wenn es halt ein Drama zum Beispiel ist,
dann stimmt mich das halt richtig traurig.
Ich nehme das dann echt in meinem Kopf mit,
weil ich weiß: Okay, das ist wirklich so passiert.
Wir hatten doch mal den "Butler" geguckt.
Und der war so traurig, weil ich genau weiß,
dass in Amerika früher die Sklaverei eben so war.
Und das war ein richtig, richtig trauriger Film.
Und so was beschäftigt mich dann
und dann will ich das halt nicht gucken.
>> MURAT: Also einen Filmeabend mit Sally
würde ich nicht machen.
>> SALLY: Doch, Filmeabend mit mir ist superlustig.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Könnt ihr vielleicht ein Video
und Bilder von eurer Hochzeit zeigen
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: und erzählen?" Oh, doch!
Ich glaube, Marcel, ich gebe dir jetzt Filmmaterial.
Hau rein!
>> MARCEL: Ihr habt sie gehört. Sie besteht drauf.
[Musik]
>> MODERATOR: Come in, too.
Your left.
Vay ingiliz ye baktı.
Şakan!
Bak!
Sen ebedi çok klişe espriler yaz tamam.
Ich werde dieses Messer hier rausnehmen,
werde es hier reinstecken
– also werde es versuchen.
>> SALLY: Da schreibt jemand:
"Ich liebe Esel."
>> MURAT: Gut. Und ich Huhn.
O mein Gott! Es kommt zu mir hier!
Es kommt zu mir!
Igitt, igitt! Mach das schnell weg!
>> SALLY: "Warum habt ihr keine Haustiere?"
Weil...
>> MURAT: Doch, haben wir. Wir haben Milben, Flöhe
und Zecken.
>> SALLY: Weil wir keine Zeit haben.
Also Samira und Ela wünschen sich gerne einen Hund.
>> MURAT: Also wir würden uns auch gern einen wünschen,
aber es ist wirklich...
>> SALLY: Aber es ist so viel Verantwortung.
>> MURAT: Du brauchst die Verantwortung
und das können wir...
>> SALLY: Außerdem haben wir Yoshi als Bürohund.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der kommt und geht.
>> MURAT: Der gehört dem Siamak, der ist immer da.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Was macht dich sauer?"
>> MURAT: Hitschies.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Die sauren?
>> MURAT: Ja, die sauren Hitschies.
>> SALLY: Mich macht – was macht mich sauer?
Wenn ich so meinen Tag voll strukturiert habe
und richtig weiß, was ich machen will,
und er kommt rein und sagt so:
"Hey Josh, Sally, Sarah, könnt ihr mal ganz schnell,
ganz kurz das Video machen für die und die?"
Und ich weiß aber, dass dieses "ganz kurz"
dich drei Stunden beschäftigen wird
und ich dann bis 20 Uhr noch dastehe
und alles andere fertig mache.
Dann bin echt kurz sauer,
weil ich dann so sage: "Murat,
dann sag es doch montags in der Montagsbesprechung."
>> MURAT: Ich mache das gern.
>> SALLY: "Seid ihr mehr türkisch oder mehr deutsch?"
Manchmal so, manchmal so.
>> MURAT: Ja, es kommt drauf an.
>> SALLY: Es gibt Situationen, da bin ich sehr türkisch.
Und dann gibt es welche, da bin ich eher deutsch.
"Würdet ihr euch wegen der Karriere trennen,
wie es viele im Showbiz machen?"
"Hoffentlich nie", schreibt sie noch dazu.
>> MURAT: Nee, niemals.
>> SALLY: Niemals.
"Wer fährt besser Auto von euch?"
>> MURAT & SALLY: Ich.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Stimmt doch gar nicht!
Du kannst gar nicht einparken.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: lehrer_ralf fragt:
Vermisst du deine Zeit in Moers?
>> MURAT: Ach Gott, mein...
Das ist mein Klassenlehrer.
Der stalkt mich auf Instagram.
Ja.
Ja, ich vermisse die Zeit in Moers.
Moers und Pforzheim sind meiner Meinung nach
– das ist jetzt meine persönliche Meinung,
ohne jemanden zu haten –
die hässlichsten Städte ganz Deutschlands.
Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Das ist krass,
dass du in Moers deine Ausbildung gemacht hast
und ich in Pforzheim und beide sind echt hässliche Städte.
>> MURAT: Nee, echt hässliche Städte. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Ist echt so.
>> MURAT: Ihr könnt nichts dafür.
Ihr wohnt dort wahrscheinlich schon länger.
>> SALLY: Ja, Pforzheim wurde halt zerbombt.
>> MURAT: Aber ja...
>> SALLY: Ja.
Na ja.
"Bereust du es, dass du ein großes Haus hast,
wegen dem Putzen?"
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ich muss echt sagen,
ich vermisse die alte Wohnung.
Ich weiß, wir haben damals geschimpft,
dass Ela dann kein Zimmer hat und keine Ahnung,
aber ich vermisse es,
in eineinhalb Stunden
die komplette Wohnung fertig geputzt zu haben.
Das vermisse ich wirklich.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und es ist wirklich
– also ich muss auch sagen, wir haben
deutlich mehr Arbeit, deutlich weniger Freizeit,
weil wir ein Haus gebaut haben.
Und ich glaube, so geht es vielen.
>> MURAT: Kannst du dich noch erinnern,
wo ich am Dienstag staubsaugen gegangen bin
und war erst am Donnerstag wieder da?
>> SALLY: "Warum ist Murat so antivegan?"
>> MURAT: Ich bin nicht antivegan.
Wirklich nicht.
Ich finde das echt toll.
Veganismus finde ich wirklich toll.
Ich mag nur nicht dieses Vorwurfsvolle,
dieses "Ihr müsst alles und das und das".
Und so geht es mir mit allem.
Verstehst du?
Dass man einem immer seinen Willen aufzwingen möchte.
Ich finde das doch auch toll, wenn einer das zu mir sagt.
Und ich gehe zu einer Würstchenbude mit dem Volkan essen
und dann
– ich weiß, dass der Volkan Veganer ist.
Dann
esse ich trotzdem mein Würstchen
und sage: "Volkan, iss halt
>> SALLY: Pommes.
>> MURAT: die Pflanze."
>> MURAT: Das mache ich dann.
Ja. Also ich finde das einfach nur...
>> SALLY: Eigentlich ist der Murat ein sehr...
>> MURAT: Menschen zu etwas zu zwingen, finde ich ganz
– das finde ich, einfach so immer:
"O Gott, nee! Und das und das."
Oder weißt, so...
So, weißt, wenn einer zum Beispiel sagt:
"Oh, ich esse jetzt Fleisch",
dann heißt es: "Ja, dafür ist eine Kuh gestorben"
oder ein Huhn oder so was.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, bei dir ist es...
>> MURAT: Weißt, ich sage doch dann auch nicht:
"Auf deine Pflanze hat jemand draufgeschissen."
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ich mache das ja auch nicht schlecht.
Und das finde ich halt
– das finde ich nicht okay.
>> SALLY: Der Murat ist eigentlich supertolerant.
Er mag es nur nicht, wenn man ihm etwas
>> MURAT: aufzwingt.
>> SALLY: – wenn man ihn bevormundet
oder ihm was aufzwingt.
>> MURAT & SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ansonsten finde ich das saucool. Ehrlich.
Es könnte sich jeder vegan ernähren. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Du auch?
>> MURAT: Nee.
Wieso?
Ich bin gesund.
So.
Aber, wenn das jemand macht, ich finde es echt toll.
Ich würde das sogar
– wenn meine Töchter sagen,
sie möchten sich vegan ernähren,
dann würde ich sagen: "Okay."
>> SALLY: "Dann koch aber selber."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Okay.
>> MURAT: "So. Ihr seid enterbt. Fertig."
Aber ich finde es toll. Wirklich.
Ohne Witz. Ich will keine Veganer haten.
>> SALLY: "Wie viele Sprachen könnt ihr sprechen?"
>> MURAT: Ich spreche Türkisch,
>> SALLY: Ben Türkçe konuşuyorum.
>> MURAT: Deutsch.
>> SALLY: Ich spreche Deutsch.
>> MURAT: I can speak English
just a bit.
>> SALLY: Je parle français.
Sell hammer halbe dacht.
Das ist Schwäbisch.
>> MURAT: Schwäbisch.
Schwäbisch finde ich auch eine coole Sprache.
Ich spreche das immer, wenn ich daheim bin.
Ja.
>> SALLY: "Ist Murat bei dir in der Firma angestellt?"
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber erst auf 400€-Basis.
>> MURAT: Das war zwei Jahre lang.
Das war aus steuerlichen Gründen.
>> SALLY: Ich frage mich:
Warum fragt uns jemand nach unseren Schuhgrößen?
>> MURAT: Wer fragt nach einer Schuhgröße?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es nicht.
>> MURAT: Wie ist das?
Wieso schreibt ihr das?
>> SALLY: Was stimmt bei euch nicht?
Warum fragt mich jemand,
ob unser Boxspringbett
atmungsaktiv ist?
>> MURAT: Keine Ahnung, warum er das macht.
Also ganz lieb:
Unser Boxspringbett ist wirklich atmungsaktiv.
>> SALLY: Und dann:
>> SALLY & MURAT: "Welche Socken hast du an?
>> MURAT: Zeig sie mal im Bild."
>> SALLY: Ich habe Strumpfhosen an.
>> MURAT: Ich habe immer schwarze Socken an.
>> SALLY: "Schnarcht Murat?"
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aber nur
– weiß du, wann ich schnarche?
>> SALLY: Wann?
>> MURAT: Wenn ich scharf gegessen habe.
Ehrlich. Wenn ich scharf gegessen habe, dann schnarche ich.
>> SALLY: Also jeden Tag.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Echt so.
>> MURAT: Nein, wenn ich scharf bin, ist was anderes.
Ja.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann würde ich sagen,
kommen wir jetzt zu unserem "Wer würde eher ...?".
Ich gebe jetzt Josh das Handy und ihr habt
den Satz vervollständigt.
Und wir müssen das Schildchen hochhalten, okay?
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Çak!
>> JOSH: Okay. Jetzt geht es zu "Wer würde eher ...?"
[Jubel]
Ihr kennt die Regeln?
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ohne Vorankündigung Schild hochhalten,
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: ohne ein Blatt vor den Mund zu nehmen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Wer würde eher sich einen Bungeesprung trauen?
>> MURAT: Stimmt das?
>> SALLY: Oh ja, als würde ich das machen!
>> MURAT: Doch, das wäre
– wenn du fehlen würdest, dann hätte ich alles noch.
Okay.
Also würdest du nicht?
>> SALLY: Deswegen würde ich es nicht machen.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher Veganer werden?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
100 Prozent.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher
vergessen, wo er sein Auto geparkt hat?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
Was ist das für eine Frage?!
Jeden Tage frage ich mich,
wo ich das Auto geparkt habe.
Ich frage mich jeden Tag, wie ich nach Hause komme.
Und wessen Kinder des morgens sind,
das frage ich mich auch.
Ja.
>> JOSH: Gut, dann haben wir auch schon die nächste Frage:
Wer würde eher die Kinder vergessen?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
>> SALLY: Hat er auch schon.
>> MURAT: Habe ich schon so oft.
Unglaublich!
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher drei Tage nicht duschen gehen?
>> MURAT: Ja...
Ja, wenn es
– wenn die Wasserpreise steigen.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher
eine Woche ohne Handy aushalten?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
>> SALLY: Er schafft es nicht mal einen Tag.
>> MURAT: Niemals. In 100 Jahren nicht.
Ich muss den Zuschauern immer antworten.
>> JOSH: ... noch ein drittes Kind wollen?
>> SALLY: Ah! Meine Hormone!
>> MURAT: Wir können gleich loslegen.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Dann haben wir gleich noch die nächste passend dazu:
Wer würde eher das Kondom durchschneiden,
um noch ein Kind zu bekommen?
>> MURAT: Wer stellt solche Fragen?!
Ich mache das nicht!
Hör auf! Meine Mutter
– meine Eltern schauen zu.
Mach das nicht.
>> SALLY: Ich antworte darauf nicht.
>> MURAT: Wir antworten nicht darauf. So.
Wer kommt denn... Wir machen...
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher einen Fehler zugeben?
>> SALLY: Ich sage, wenn ich was falsch gemacht habe.
Du schiebst es auf andere.
>> MURAT: Ich würde es erst versuchen
auf die Kinder zu schieben.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weil denen glaubt man...
>> SALLY: Dann auf Yoshi, auf den Hund.
>> MURAT: Auf den Hund.
Und wenn es...
Ja, ich glaube, du würdest eher einen Fehler zugeben, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
War das ein Fehler, dass wir geheiratet haben?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Wer würde eher so machen,
als ob er den anderen nicht kennt, für peinliches Verhalten?
>> SALLY: Sorry.
Aber wie oft standen wir schon im Supermarkt,
du haust irgendeinen peinlichen Spruch raus
>> MURAT: Ah, das war richtig cool.
Ach Gott, das war so cool!
>> SALLY: und ich laufe einfach weg,
als würde ich ihn nicht kennen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ganz ehrlich.
>> MURAT: Das mache ich voll gern.
Ich bringe dich voll gern in peinliche Situationen.
>> SALLY: Der bringt mich richtig oft...
>> MURAT: Oh, das mache ich voll gern! Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann heißt es:
"Sally, warum bist du so zum Murat?"
>> MURAT: Aber weißt du, warum ich das mache?
Weil ich einfach...
Ich mag das, wenn ich
– wirklich, ich sehe das voll gern,
wie jemand auf eine peinliche Situation reagiert.
Aber, wenn es dann die Person betrifft,
nicht mich selber.
Aber, wenn sie dann
– boah, ich liebe das voll!
Weil ich denke mir dann:
"Okay. Wie reagiert sie jetzt einfach auf die Schnelle?"
Ich liebe das voll.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher
im Einzelhandel um Rabatte handeln?
>> SALLY: Mir ist so was ganz peinlich.
>> MURAT: Mir auch.
>> SALLY: Also ich auch kein Basargänger oder so.
>> MURAT: Ich mag das auch nicht.
Also ich kann es nicht.
>> SALLY: Ich kann das nicht.
>> MURAT: Ich tu nie verhandeln.
>> SALLY: Ich auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Also egal, was ich mache...
Wenn jetzt jemand mir ein Auto verkaufen möchte
und er sagt mir den Preis
– dann frage ich nach dem Preis, dann sagt er mir den Preis.
Ich tu da niemals verhandeln.
Weil ich finde das immer...
Stell dir mal vor
– kennst du das, wenn jemand ein Auto von dir kaufen möchte
und du sagst dann
– nur ein Beispiel:
Du sagst dann, 4.000 € willst du für das Auto haben.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und dann kommt die Person und sagt:
"2.000 € bezahle ich."
>> SALLY: Oh nee, ich könnte das nicht. Da bin ich schon raus.
>> MURAT: Dann bin ich so stinksauer,
dann sage ich: "Dann hau ab!"
Wirklich ganz ehrlich.
Und deswegen, weil ich das einfach unfair finde.
Ich frage einmal nach dem Preis und dann ist es einfach so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Was ich auch nicht mache:
Wenn zum Beispiel...
Oftmals, wenn es jetzt um Gehaltsverhandlungen geht,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: dann frage ich immer:
"Okay, was möchtest du verdienen?"
Und dann sagt mir die Person etwas
und dann tu ich nicht verhandeln.
Dann sage ich: "Okay, das
>> SALLY: Entweder passt es ins Budget oder halt nicht.
>> MURAT: passt" oder nicht. Ich würde niemals verhandeln
und sagen: "Nee, jetzt kriegst du 100 € weniger" oder 200 €.
Ich würde das niemals machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also verhandeln hasse ich über alles.
Das mache ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Ich auch nicht.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher sich vorstellen können,
von jetzt auf gleich alles zu packen
und in die Türkei zu ziehen?
>> SALLY: Wenn meine Eltern mitgehen und meine Freunde.
>> MURAT: Okay, dann bleibe ich hier.
Darf ich das wählen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Wer würde eher lügen?
>> SALLY: Ganz klar.
Eine Notlüge ist auch eine Lüge, Murat.
>> MURAT: Der Mensch lügt mindestens hundertmal am Tag.
>> SALLY: Ja, und du dreihundertmal.
>> MURAT: Kannst du dich noch erinnern,
wo du schwanger warst?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich habe ständig gelogen.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Du sahst aus
wie ein Stern.
Wie ein schöner Stern!
Ja.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher in der Öffentlichkeit pupsen
und es dann auf den anderen schieben?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
>> SALLY: Das macht der ständig!
>> MURAT: Das habe ich gestern gemacht im Auto.
>> SALLY: Immer, wenn wir im Auto sind. Mein Gott!
>> MURAT: Aber ich finde das so lustig!
>> SALLY: Sarah und Josh hinten drin und der furzt einfach.
>> MURAT: Aber ich schwöre:
>> SALLY: Das Auto hat gestunken, als wären wir an einem
>> MURAT: Da könnte eine Kuh
>> SALLY: Gully vorbeigefahren.
>> MURAT: neben mir stehen, die würden sagen:
"Er hat es gemacht."
100 Prozent. Das weiß ich.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher den Fluchtwagen fahren?
>> MURAT: Ah, ich. Den sollte ich fahren normalerweise.
>> SALLY: Den sollte ich fahren.
>> MURAT: Mh.
Das hat nichts mit einparken zu tun,
wollte ich jetzt nur mal so nebenher.
Das würde ich machen.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher nachts aufstehen,
um aus dem Kühlschrank zu naschen?
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
Mache ich echt oft.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber irgendwie...
>> SALLY: Und er lässt die leere Verpackung drin.
Deswegen weiß ich dann immer, was er genascht hat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Übrigens gestern
– ich kann ja jetzt ganz ehrlich sein.
Ich habe gestern Chips gegessen
und zwar nachts um 1 Uhr
und noch vom Weihnachtsmann den Kopf.
Ja.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher
eine Prüfung im Dschungelcamp schaffen?
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich würde...
>> MURAT: 100 Prozent.
Ich würde es eher schaffen,
ich würde es aber in 100 Jahren nicht machen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Die finde ich einfach...
>> SALLY: Ich würde es nicht schaffen.
>> MURAT: Ich finde die ganze Serie, die ganze
– wäh!
>> SALLY: Puh!
>> MURAT: Wirklich!
Aber ich würde es machen, weil ich weiß ganz genau,
sobald sie irgendein Tier sieht, was mehr als vier Beine hat,
ist die weg aus dem Dschungel.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann fliege ich weg.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aber eigentlich gibt es ja einen Spruch.
Der geht ja so:
"Zeig mir deinen Content,
ich sage dir, wer deine Zuschauer sind."
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und bei uns schreiben sie alle
über das Auswandern, Bungee-Jumping und Fußfetischisten.
Ich glaube, es gibt...
>> SALLY: Was sagt das jetzt über uns aus?
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, es gibt eine Facebook-Gruppe,
die sich nur über meine Füße unterhält.
100 Prozent.
>> SALLY: Saban ist der Administrator.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja, 100 Prozent.
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> MURAT: Ich will schon meine Füße gar nicht mehr zeigen,
weil ich Angst habe, dass sich da jemand aufgeilt.
Ich habe keinen Bock drauf.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher vom 10-Meter-Brett springen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich würde – ich kann so was nicht.
Ich kann nicht mal vom Beckenrand springen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
10 Meter fange ich gar nicht an.
>> SALLY: Ich kann nicht mal vom Beckenrand.
>> MURAT: Ich war mal Klippenspringer.
>> SALLY: Nee, ich kann es nicht.
>> MURAT: Bis im Pool kein Wasser mehr war.
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher den anderen hauen?
>> SALLY: Ich würde es mal gerne tun.
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, sie würde es.
Ich glaube, das wärst eher du.
>> SALLY: Ach Quatsch! Ich haue dich doch nicht.
>> MURAT: Doch. Hast du mir
– jetzt ohne Spaß. Hast du mir nicht schon mal
eine Ohrfeige gegeben? Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Nein, das war aus Versehen.
>> MURAT: Hm, klar.
>> SALLY: Das war...
>> MURAT: Drei Wochen lang so
und dann habe ich erzählt, ich bin die Treppen runtergefallen.
>> SALLY: Das war wirklich aus Versehen.
>> MURAT: Kannst du dich echt nicht mehr erinnern?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich weiß, da war irgendwas
und dann habe ich gesagt: "Und dann machst du das so."
Und ich habe dir aus Versehen voll eine...
>> MURAT: Nee, nee. Nee, nee. Ich kann mich noch erinnern.
>> SALLY: Doch!
>> MURAT: Ich kann mich noch erinnern.
>> SALLY: Das war nicht ich.
Dann war das eine Exfreundin von dir. Sorry.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber ich habe dich nie wissentlich geschlagen.
>> MURAT: Doch. Ich glaube, einmal
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: hast du mich geschlagen.
>> SALLY: Ich würde es manchmal gern tun.
>> MURAT: Jetzt gib es doch wenigstens zu.
Lügen tut sie auch noch.
>> SALLY: Einfach, damit er ruhig ist,
einfach so zack.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Hundertmal schon:
Wer würde eher in der Öffentlichkeit pupsen?
>> MURAT: Sag mal, was ist denn los?
>> SALLY: Die Leute!
>> MURAT: Stellt doch mal Fragen
– kann man nicht auch mal Fragen stellen,
wo einen Menschen irgendwie weiterbringen?
Guck mal. Das ist genau das, das sind deine Zuschauer.
Weil meine Zuschauer,
>> SALLY: Komm. Dann lass uns noch mal so drei Fragen...
>> MURAT: die gucken sich Dokumentationsfilme an,
die wollen sich politisch bilden.
>> SALLY: Drei Fragen...
>> MURAT: Und deine fragen sich dann,
wer am ehesten furzen würde.
Aua! Hör auf!
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Habe ich es doch gerade gesagt.
>> SALLY: Können wir kurz drei Fragen einfach
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: so als Abschluss?
>> JOSH: Wer würde eher
dem ersten Freund der Tochter nachspionieren?
>> SALLY: Definitiv.
Hast du gerade aufgestoßen?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hast du gerade gerülpst?
>> MURAT: Ja, vor lauter Wut.
Vor lauter Wut.
Ich glaube, das würde ich machen.
>> SALLY: Definitiv. Und ich würde das
– ich würde wissen, wie ich dich daran hindere.
>> MURAT: Ich würde.
Ich will das gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, dann würde ich dich ein-
>> MURAT: Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
>> SALLY: Da war neulich echt ein Schulfreund
von Samira da. Ich nenne jetzt keine Namen.
>> MURAT: Und es war richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Ich nenne keine Namen. Es ist so peinlich!
Es war so peinlich!
Die wäre am liebsten im Erdboden versunken.
Und das sind einfach Schulfreunde.
Die hat ja noch keinen Freund oder so.
Das sind Schulfreunde.
>> MURAT: Hm. So fängt es an.
>> SALLY: Die spielen, die lernen.
>> MURAT: So fängt es an.
>> SALLY: Stimmt doch gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann sitzen wir am Tisch
und dann sagt der Murat einfach so
– und der Junge heißt nicht Olaf.
Der weiß ganz genau, wie der Junge heißt.
Dann sagt er so:
"Ah, hi, Olaf.
Olaf war der Name, oder?"
Und er so: "Nee, ich heiße anders."
Und der Murat so:
"Ach, ich habe den Namen schon ganz vergessen.
Bei Samira kommen jeden Tag die Jungs rein und raus.
Da kann ich mir nicht alle Namen merken."
Und ich sitze so am Tisch.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Das ist wirklich heftig.
>> SALLY: Mein Wutauge so von Sarah.
So.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Und die Samira so:
"Papa. Papa!"
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das war so peinlich!
>> MURAT: Ja, ich weiß!
>> SALLY: Das hast du richtig absichtlich gemacht.
>> MURAT: Ich weiß, ich weiß!
Halt! Stopp! Jetzt rede ich.
>> SALLY: Die ist doch noch ein Kind!
>> MURAT: Das ist mir egal.
>> SALLY: Die hat doch keinen Freund.
>> SALLY: Das ist ein Spielfreund.
>> MURAT: Mir egal. Meine Tochter.
>> SALLY: Oh, wow!
Er würde auch nachspionieren, aber ich sage es euch:
>> MURAT: Würde ich auch machen. Wirklich.
Das würde ich echt machen. Ich würde es auch zugeben.
>> SALLY: Ich würde es manipulieren.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich würde es auch zugeben.
Sorry.
>> SALLY: Komm, letzte Frage.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Wer würde den Kindern eher Hausarrest geben?
>> SALLY: Der Murat, weil er sich dann
– weil er nicht wüsste, dass er sich damit selbst bestraft.
In 100 Jahren würde ich
meinem Kind keinen Hausarrest erteilen.
>> MURAT: Jeden Tag, am Tag dreimal.
>> SALLY: Ich war auch nie eine Lehrerin,
die Nachsitzen erteilt hat.
Denn dann bestrafst du dich doch selber damit.
Dann musst du mit dem Kind zu Hause bleiben,
den ganzen Tag, die ganze Woche.
>> MURAT: Aber ich schließe die Tür immer ab.
Und dann schiebe ich halt
– ab und zu mache ich auf
und dann schiebe ich einen Schluck Wasser rein.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich bin der Papa, wo ihr immer sagen würdet:
"Das ist nicht mein Papa.
Ich kenne diesen Mann nicht!
>> SALLY: So sagt Samira immer.
>> MURAT: Kann jemand die Polizei rufen?
Ich kenne diesen Mann nicht."
>> SALLY: So im Auto drin.
>> MURAT: Ja, "Hilfe". So ein Zettel, so "Hilfe".
>> SALLY: Also es waren echt witzige Fragen.
Allerdings frage ich mich,
warum jede dritte Frage darum ging,
ob wir einen Bungeesprung machen würden,
auswandern würden,
wer eher drei Tage nicht duscht
und unsere Schuhgröße.
>> MURAT: Und um irgendwelche Körpergeräusche.
Mitunter
schade.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss sagen,
dieses Jahr, wie gesagt, dieses letzte Video in diesem Jahr.
Zurückblicken können wir vielleicht
auf ein oder zwei lustige Szenen.
Also dieses Jahr wäre uns einmal
fast die Küche abgebrannt.
[Musik]
[Feuerwehrsirenen]
>> SARAH: Breaking News aus Waghäusel.
Wir haben 12:35 Uhr
und bei Sally ging der Rauchmelder an.
Wir sind natürlich live vor Ort
und können der besagten Sally ein paar Fragen stellen.
Sally, wie kam es dazu?
>> SALLY: Ich weiß es auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Was ist passiert?
>> SALLY: Es ging im Prinzip damit los:
Ich habe den Ofen auf zehn Minuten eingestellt.
Da sahen die Kekse noch perfekt aus.
>> SARAH: Aha, aha.
>> SALLY: Aber sie waren noch nicht durch
und ich habe sie noch mal fünf Minuten nachgestellt.
Und jetzt ist einfach...
Es ist einfach zerstört. Der Rauchmelder
>> SARAH: Wow!
>> SALLY: ging an. Die Kekse sind verbrannt.
Ich kann es mir auch nicht erklären.
>> SARAH: Wir haben das Phänomen gelöst.
Auch bei Sallys Welt
in der Küche geht mal was schief.
>> SALLY: Es lag einfach an der
veganen Butter.
>> SARAH: Oh! Was lernen wir daraus?
>> SALLY: Ich backe wieder mit der richtigen Butter.
>> SARAH: Richtige Butter nehmen, sonst verbrennt es.
>> SALLY: Ja, oder die richtige vegane Margarine.
Aber bitte probiert es nicht mit Kokosfett.
Kokosfett
>> SARAH: verbrennt.
Vielen Dank für das Interview.
Wir verlassen den Raum.
>> SALLY: Darf ich noch jemanden grüßen?
>> SARAH: Sonst erleiden wir eine Rauchvergiftung.
Wen wollen Sie denn grüßen?
>> SALLY: Meinen Mann Murat,
der
bitte die Kekse entsorgen soll.
>> SARAH: Okay.
Murat.
Tschüss, Sally.
>> SALLY: Tschüss.
[Musik]
Was dieses Jahr auch ganz besonders war:
Dass der Sturmi zum ersten Mal bei uns zu Gast war.
>> MURAT: Sturmwaffel war da.
>> SALLY: Ja, und das war echt schön.
Also er war ja mehrere Tage da
und wir hatten richtig viel Spaß.
Vor allem habe ich ja den Sturmi
jeden Tag mit Karaokegesang überrascht.
Und ich glaube, er konnte mit seinen Emotionen
nie so richtig umgehen, gell?
Der konnte seine Emotionen nicht sammeln.
>> MURAT: Ich habe ja schon gedacht,
Corona ist schlimm und dann kommt der Sturmi.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> FREDERIC: Aber ist doch gut, nicht?
>> SALLY: Das ist echt gut.
> FREDERIC: Was hast du da?
>> MURAT: Hey, das ist ein Monk. Pass du auf, ey!
>> FREDERIC: Ist das dein Ernst gerade?
>> SALLY: Was dann noch besonders war:
Dass Eko Fresh da war.
Also wir haben ja unser neues Format gestartet,
"Zu Gast bei Sally".
>> MURAT: Der Held meiner Jugend.
>> SALLY: Ja, ist echt so, meiner Jugend auch.
Und es war echt...
Okay, ich bin jünger als du.
>> MURAT: Du bist Grundschullehrerin.
Du hast mit Sicherheit kein Eko Fresh gehört.
>> SALLY: Ich habe auch Eko Fresh gehört.
>> MURAT: Echt? Okay.
>> SALLY: Der beste auf der Welt.
>> MURAT: Okay. Hör mal auf.
>> SALLY: Denn er ist jung und braucht
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: das Geld. Er lebe hoch!
>> MURAT: Okay.
Soll ich es mal kurz machen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Komm, Murat.
>> SARAH: Komm, Murat. Du bist der Joker.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Das gibt es doch nicht!
>> SALLY: Wenn er es jetzt reintrifft,
dann mache ich mir echt Sorgen um mich.
>> MURAT: So.
Ich zeige es mal, wie es der Hauptschüler macht.
[Applaus]
>> EKREM: Wuh!
>> SARAH: Hey!
>> MURAT: Sehr schön.
[Applaus]
Du hast Glück, dass du den richtigen Mann geheiratet hast.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo?
>> MURAT: Danke schön!
Es war schön.
Habe ich jetzt gewonnen?
Ich glaube, das Spiel habe ich gewonnen jetzt. Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Du hast gewonnen.
>> EKREM: Du hast die ganze Challenge jetzt gewonnen.
>> SARAH: Ihr könnt den Punkt an Murat geben.
>> SALLY: Man muss auch sagen, dass Ela und Samira
– die werden ja echt immer größer
und die haben ja auch dieses Jahr
auch mal alleine gebacken.
Weißt du noch? Die Smarties-Muffins?
>> MURAT: Ja, die waren cool.
Die haben sie zusammen gebacken.
>> SALLY: Die zwei, die machen das echt süß.
>> MURAT: Wir haben halt in der Corona-Zeit
Die haben ja, die waren ja...
Die waren ständig im Lockdown,
weil irgendjemand in der Klasse
infiziert war oder die Lehrerin war infiziert
oder die Schule war infiziert oder
>> SALLY: Irgendwas war infiziert.
>> MURAT: Nachbars Hund war infiziert.
Und jedes Mal waren sie zu Hause.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja.
>> MURAT: Und deswegen haben wir halt
die Kinder oft beschäftigt und
– Backen, Kochen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Dann habe ich sie ein paar Mal eingesperrt.
Sie sind wieder rausgekommen.
Ja,
>> SALLY: Ganz alleine.
>> MURAT: war lustig dieses Jahr.
>> ELA: Mama, kann ich dir den allerwitzigsten
Witz erzählen?
>> SALLY: Einen Witz?
Ja, erzähl.
>> ELA: Ja.
Eine Karotte ist in der Rubine drin.
Und dann geht die Karotte
in die Eier rein und macht ein Eierbad.
>> SALLY: Wer hat gerade gepupst?
>> ELA: Ich nicht.
>> SAMIRA: Ich nicht.
>> SALLY: Viel Spaß, Josh!
>> SAMIRA: Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Samiras und...
[Trommelwirbel]
>> ELA: Samira soll es sagen.
>> SAMIRA: Ach!
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Samiras und Elas Welt!
>> ELA: Naa! Na, na, na, na!
>> SALLY: Ich weiß nicht, nach wem sie kommt.
Kommst du nach dem Papa?
Ja.
Nach oben rollen.
Jetzt den Rand einschlagen.
>> ELA: Der Rand ist nicht so wie die Blätter.
Das ist Murat.
>> SALLY: Warum?
>> ELA: Weil er echt dick ist.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> ELA: Dick wie ein Rollbrötchen!
>> SALLY: O Ela!
>> ELA: Dick wie ein Rollenbrötchen!
>> SALLY: Ein Elsazopf!
Die kannst du auch mit zur Schule nehmen
oder zum Kindergarten.
Gehst du schon zur Schule?
>> ELA: Nee!
>> SALLY: Was man auch sagen muss:
Dadurch, dass eben das Corona-Jahr kam,
– eigentlich wollte ich in diesem Video
das Wort nicht in den Mund nehmen, aber es war halt so –
sind ja auch die Messen ausgefallen.
Und dann haben wir ja kurzerhand beschlossen
und mit Bosch sozusagen
die Messe zu uns nach Hause geholt,
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: die IFA.
Und das war ziemlich cool,
weil wir echt unser Haus auf den Kopf gestellt haben.
>> MURAT: Und wir haben Berlin nach Waghäusel geholt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und man hat in der Branche natürlich gesagt:
"Krass! Die machen die IFA zu Hause in Waghäusel."
Es war eine coole Aktion, waren coole Videos auch.
Ich habe rausgefunden, was Ding heißt, Fake
– Deepfake heißt.
>> SALLY: Deepfake.
>> MURAT: Deepfake ist,
wenn mir jemand eine Sprache spricht.
Die tun deinen ganzen Mundwinkel
fotografieren oder aufnehmen
und plötzlich hauen sie eine andere Sprache rein.
>> SALLY: Ja, das war schon cool.
>> MURAT: Und dann hast du mehrere Sprachen,
ohne dass du jemals im Englischunterricht warst
oder im Französischunterricht oder Spanischunterricht.
Das finde ich,
>> SALLY: Das wäre perfekt für dich.
>> MURAT: ja, wahnsinnig!
>> SALLY: Hast du gerade gepupst oder war das...
>> MURAT: Habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur mich ein bisschen gerüttelt.
Ja.
Hä?
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall eine krasse Technik,
was da auf den Markt kommt momentan, Deepfake.
>> SALLY: O Mann!
>> MURAT: Schaut es euch mal kurz an.
>> SALLY: ... für die Zukunft ist
und sich an meine individuellen Bedürfnisse anpasst?
Welcome to HomeConnect by Bosch!
Con HomeConnect, tutti i miei elettrodomestici
sono connessi in modo intellige.
Ik hoef maar twee dingen te doen:
de HomeConnect-app downloaden
en mijn apparaten aan de app koppelen.
Damit kann ich meine Hausgeräte
ganz einfach über mein Smartphone oder Tablet steuern.
Egal von wo.
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay.
Hätte ich gewusst, dass es diese Technik mal gibt,
wäre ich zum Beispiel
gar nicht mehr in den Englischunterricht gegangen.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Es ist echt so.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss auch sagen:
Die Woche war für mich sehr anstrengend
und ich war ziemlich übermüdet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Deswegen verzeiht mir auch
den einen oder anderen emotionalen
– wie sage ich da? –
Ausbruch.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn
manchmal kommt es einfach aus mir raus
und dann teile ich das mit euch.
Ich vermisse deinen Atem,
der mich zart berührt!
Rausschneiden.
Was soll der Geiz?
Also ich brauche noch ein bisschen Mehl bei mir.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es ein bisschen größere Eier waren
als sonst.
>> JOSH: Okay, für die Weihnachtsfeier.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?
>> JOSH: Sarah lacht über große Eier.
>> SALLY: Bei so komischen Leuten,
die so komische Anliegen haben, denke ich jedes Mal:
"Der kommt bestimmt heute Nacht und will mich entführen
>> JOSH: Mh.
>> SALLY: und wollte nur gucken, ob ich da bin."
>> JOSH: Ich wollte es gerade sagen.
>> SALLY: Aber, wer mich entführt,
bringt mich ganz schnell wieder zurück,
wenn ich meine ABBA-Playlist auspacke.
Voulez-vous!
Aha!
Denn ich darf die Torte jetzt nicht glatt streichen.
Das wird nämlich die Geburtstagstorte,
die Hagrid Harry mitgebracht hat.
Und die war nicht glatt.
Also die darf nicht perfekt sein.
Also muss ich die jetzt so unperfekt machen.
[Trommelwirbel]
>> SAMIRA: Dann soll die der Papa machen.
>> MURAT: Auch ein Held unserer Kindheit war da.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und auch immer noch ein Held.
>> SALLY: Ja. Kai Pflaume war zu Besuch.
>> MURAT: Kai Pflaume war hier.
>> SALLY: Das war schon ein besonderer Gast,
muss ich sagen.
>> MURAT: Ja, war lustig.
>> SALLY: Ja. Vor allem hat er sich hier voll ausgetobt
und hat mit mir zum ersten Mal eine Torte gebacken.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> KAI: Ich habe eben gerade gedacht, du fragst mich,
ob ich mir zutrauen würde,
die Schokolade über den Kuchen fließen zu lassen.
>> SALLY: Oh, das würde dann ich, glaube ich, probieren.
>> KAI: Hm.
So weit geht das...
>> SALLY: So nach fünf Stunden Deko...
>> KAI: So weit geht das Vertrauen nicht?
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> KAI: Ah, ist ja auch gut zu wissen.
>> SALLY: Aber eine Torte
>> KAI: Ja, mach.
>> SALLY: hat ja auch eine Rückseite.
>> KAI: Mh.
Mach.
>> SALLY: Ach!
>> KAI: Aber komm mir hinterher nicht:
"Es hat nicht geklappt."
Hm.
>> SALLY: Schmecksperimente!
>> KAI: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir warten noch kurz ein, zwei Minütchen
und dann ist die Buttercreme fest.
Dann haben wir es gleich.
[Musik]
Mann, ich kann das nicht!
>> KAI: Lach nicht beim Schlafen!
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Und weiter geht's!
>> KAI: Ah!
>> SALLY: Weiter!
>> MURAT: Wenn sich manche fragen:
"Was kann Kai Pflaume nicht?",
definitiv Tischtennis spielen.
Da ist er wirklich
wie so ein Analphabet.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, er hat gesagt, er will noch mal,
er will eine Revanche, er will mit dir spielen.
>> MURAT: Nee, Kai Pflaume ist der schlechteste
Tischtennisspieler, den ich kenne.
>> SALLY: Aha!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, das war ein...
>> MURAT: Obwohl, Sturmi ist genauso schlecht.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, das war...
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Macht einen Verein!
Macht einen Selbsthilfeverein!
Ja, ich habe alle abgezockt hier.
Wirklich.
Ich habe noch nie im Tischtennis verloren.
Wenn sich jemand gern melden würde gegen mich,
ich
spiele gegen euch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Jedenfalls, finde ich,
war das in Kurzfassung unser Video zum Jahresende.
Wir packen euch noch ein paar Highlights aus diesem Jahr...
>> MURAT: Hey, die Türkeireise war voll cool!
>> SALLY: Oh, die Türkeireise!
>> MURAT: Die Olivenölreise.
>> SALLY: Es kommt übrigens...
>> MURAT: Saumäßig cool!
>> SALLY: Also Olivenöl haben wir ja schon hochgeladen.
Und es kommt übrigens auch noch ein Vlog online.
Und noch unser Besuch bei Paşabahçe in Istanbul
kommt auch noch online.
Da könnt ihr wirklich drauf gespannt sein.
Denn das war wirklich eine der schönsten Reisen.
Und ich würde sagen, wir packen jetzt einfach
noch ein paar Highlights aus unserem Jahr
ans Ende des Videos,
verabschieden uns für heute und wir sehen uns...
>> MURAT: Und verabschieden uns auch von diesem
>> SALLY: krassen,
>> MURAT: nicht idealen Jahr.
>> SALLY: nicht idealen Jahr.
Aber wir haben das Beste daraus gemacht, finde ich.
>> MURAT: Wir haben das Beste daraus – ganz genau.
>> SALLY: Für uns war echt alles
bei uns im Team
– und ich muss echt sagen,
das komplette Team hat mitgemacht.
>> MURAT: Wenn dir das Leben...
>> SALLY: Jeder Einzelne.
>> MURAT: Wenn dir das Leben Zitronen schenkt,
mach Limonade daraus.
>> SALLY: Nein, Lemon Curd.
>> MURAT: Lemon Curd, genau.
>> SALLY: Oder Lemon-Baiser-Torte.
>> MURAT: Und, wie gesagt, wir wünschen euch allen
ein frohes neues Jahr.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und das Tolle ist:
Schlimmer kann es nicht mehr werden.
>> SALLY: Oh, sag das nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay. Stimmt.
Der Optimist würde jetzt sagen:
"Doch, doch, kann es. Kann es."
Und deswegen:
Bleibt gesund. Das ist das Allerwichtigste.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und freut euch auf viele tolle neue Projekte,
die wir 2021 angehen werden.
Also es wird wirklich wieder ein turbulentes Jahr.
Wir haben neulich so eine Projektbesprechung gemacht
und irgendwie ist das ganze Jahr schon wieder rammelvoll.
Aber wir freuen uns auf jedes einzelne Projekt
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und auf euch.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Passt auf euch auf.
Passt auf eure Eltern auf und eure Opas und Omas.
Auf eure Kinder könnt ihr auch aufpassen.
Macht's gut!
>> MURAT & SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Werde nicht so anhänglich.
Drittes Kind kommt.
>> SALLY: Was würdest du sagen,
wenn ich jetzt drei Tage nicht dusche?
>> MURAT: Mh.
Nichts.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hast du gerade gesagt, das dritte Kind kommt?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Vielleicht.
>> SALLY: Ich bin nicht schwanger!
Hört auf zu fragen, ob ich schwanger bin!
[Musik]